what is the most important thing
in the universe to have food water
no internet the internet
i know you're all dying to know what my
situation with the internet is
and no i still don't have any goddamn
internet christian channel
so the wonderful people at origin pc
heard my cry
they heard my cry for help and they
reached out a helping hand
offering to send me the origin cronus so
that i can move my setup
to somewhere where they actually have
internet now the origin coronas is
pretty cool it's
the size of pretty much my
my console look at that and this beast
packs 4k
baby because let's get real here what's
the most important thing
after the internet computer now maybe
finally it won't take 100 hours for me
to upload a video thank you origin pc
i appreciate you but felix what about me
oh
me me me me me there you go again fine
okay
fine i'll give away one okay just check
out the link in the description
the role is simple just follow all the
rules and you could win one as well
in the meantime origen is also gonna
send me their origin millennium
it's got their beast they told me they
can do a custom paint job on it
so let me know in the comments what kind
of paint job they should give me the
most top voted comment
will win also the giveaway is worldwide
so anyone can sign up
all their pcs ship worldwide i really
highly recommend checking out
originpc.com
uh you can play around and customize
your own computer that comes with
lifetime
support for laughs you buy this pc you
buy it for laugh
if you don't know what origin pc is it's
basically three executives from
alienware
so they have a ton of experience to
build badass computers
and i'm really proud to have them as a
sponsor of the channel now let's move on
with the video
oh yes we're playing more
i don't care if i fell down last time
because this game is easy
stop i'm stop we're literally at the
beginning of the game are you kidding me
how far did i fall oh my god i feel now
is the happiness i had before that's the
deal
i am back at the beginning i am back at
the beginning
are your cereal oh my god i have to redo
everything
you know what easy you know why cause
guy i got power moves now son
brah i don't even care anymore
this is the easiest game [ __ ] everyone
[ __ ] everyone [ __ ] everyone i tried
so far
ah you thought i was gonna fall did ya
how do i even get up there dude [ __ ]
everyone
just do what you did first team phoenix
i know what to do my power moves
what the [ __ ] no can you use the power
mode
you hit your head dude
a peace above all earthly dignities i
want you to die
i want you to die
yeah i'm fine you know what i don't now
believe that you will ever feel better
but this is not true you're sure to be
happy again
and knowing this truly believing it will
make you less miserable now
abraham lincoln yeah if he was so smart
then
why is he dead huh [ __ ] at the end i
am beginning to believe
that i will die a horrible death
can this music shut the [ __ ] up
[Music]
oh wow look at that everybody
oh hell yeah he did it
hit shut up
look at that i am back baby
power move
good job buddy
oh my god yes
pull buddy pull like
snobbly dabbly i'm not gonna let this
game
defeat me okay it's not happening
yes you're right you make me you make me
die a million times
i'll come back for a million more baby
this is a tricky one you need a lot of
power
you need a lot of strength you need a
lot of skill
and you need a lot of swiss giant
youtube channel everybody thank you
i am back suck on my swedish nuts
i mean family friendly felix here suck
on my swedish fish
they are the delish
the dad this game is so easy legit i eat
this game for breakfast
all right hey hey
hey hey oh look a look at me
look at me i'm just a man sucking a pot
just a slit stuck up
hey look at that boy i did it oh yeah
okay we're almost back to oh
we are almost back to where we were how
about that
this one is really tricky because you
need a lot of core strength
easy just kidding i trick you all right
we're back
this is it right 10 minutes
casual this game is for cash ah
this game is for casuals all right my
grandma would love this game
she'd be like oh do you have anything
more difficult than this barbie ass
looking piece of [ __ ] dog ha ha
i am mickey mouse your grandmother
pewdiepie
okay all right this do not stand at my
grave and cry
really you're gonna put really really
you can it it's fine it's
fine to live [ __ ] you
friend i prince philosophers in my game
look how deep it is all of a sudden
[Music]
i'm gonna get up this [ __ ] no no
come on oh my god
okay okay mr slide okay mr slide
hello mr slide how you doing everybody
don't hurt me i've been hurt too many
times
hey mr ball don't mind if i ball
you a question oh god what the hell is
that kid doing there
can i grab this oh it's an illusion it's
an illusion everybody it's an illusion
incredible what they can do this oh god
okay i'm just gonna chill here
now am i supposed to jump over to that
side
i feel like that's what's happening here
oh that's fun that's fun that's i love
slides first of all
f you little child for trying to kill me
second of all second of all sayonara
[ __ ]
oh okay now where do i go
power move oh oh oh oh oh
fine fine
oh i hate this i'm not even sad
okay i'm just mad i'm just
upset hey buddy
there you go
relax relax relax relax
you're fine you're doing fine
i'm doing fine no thanks
stop the slide just don't fall through
the hole
felix and you're fine you're fine hey
look at me i'm fine
i think my hammer is stuck oh
it oh my god it's stuck oh no
oh no no okay i'm fine jesus
supposed to be my friend hammer
don't grunt at me old man
what are you doing focus
stop oh my god oh
my god
stop it felix stop it
the water slide is so annoying
there that was [ __ ] smooth that was
smooth
ass a balloon wow felix do you speak
english with that
language
solo
this is really interesting because it
would seem that
we have to go down all the sudden which
is not a reoccurring theme in this game
oh god all right okay and now we're just
gonna
oh my god
pull yourself together man pull yourself
together
we did it everybody ah that was easy
my god when was the game was difficult
now what i'm gonna do might seem like a
bad idea
but if you're a genius like myself
you would realize the true power [ __ ]
ah it's fine it's fine
it's fine i am fine
i'm fine i'm fine i'm fine
listen listen i'm already back i'm
already back to where i'm starting
no you didn't oh wow that [ __ ] kills
me every time
no do not fall down there we discussed
this
no stop
if that was a whoopee dooley then how
come i am already back in action baby
stronger than ever huh explain that
you